as we continue Peter Doocy is upon in
Washington with some info Peter
Brett we've now heard from the top
Democrats in Congress Nancy Pelosi who
recently said that she's not interested
in pursuing impeachment proceedings at
any point against President Trump and
Chuck Schumer who said let's just wait
for the Muller report so I'm gonna read
to from a joint statement from both
Pelosi and Schumer it says now that
special counsel Muller has submitted his
report to the Attorney General it is
imperative for mr. Barr to make the full
report public and provide its underlying
documentation and findings to Congress
attorney general Barr must not give
President Trump his lawyers or his staff
any sneak preview of special counsel
Mahler's findings or evidence and the
White House must not be allowed to
interfere in decisions about what parts
of those findings or evidence are made
public the special counsels
investigation focused on questions that
go to the integrity of our democracy
itself whether foreign powers corruptly
interfered in our elections and whether
unlawful means were used to hinder that
investigation the American people have a
right to the truth the watchword is
transparency and separate from that Bret
I just spoke on the phone to a key Trump
ally on the Republican side
on Capitol Hill who said the fact that
we found out the report had been
submitted but did not instantly find out
about new indictments this lawmaker
thinks is a positive step for the
president and again Republicans are seem
pleased at least for now
that the word collusion has not been
used by anybody at the Justice
Department even though we don't know
what's in the report Brett yeah Peter
thank you